think the iMac Pro is canceled think
again we just got confirmation that
apple is working on two brand new iMacs
with apple silicon chips from our German
who also gave us some very specific and
important details that can help us
answer a lot of important questions
including the differences between both
iMac models the pricing that we should
expect the chip options for each one the
features and of course the release dates
so let's jump right into it over this
past weekend Mark confirmed that Apple's
long-awaited 24-inch iMac refresh is
going to be coming with an M3 chip
either later this fall or in the spring
of 2024 and I completely agree because
if the iMac was gonna get the current M2
Chip they would have unveiled it at WWDC
but that didn't happen so it's gonna
have to wait until the M3 chip is ready
which will likely be later this fall all
which in my opinion points to a release
date of the M3 24-inch iMac in the
spring and as far as the features specs
and details I'm expecting this iMac to
literally just be a chip swap and
nothing else from the M1 over to the M3
with apple skipping the M2 which is
basically giving it a three year kind of
tick tock update cycle now the 24 inch
iMac that we have right now is already
great in terms of design and really
nothing else needs to be updated except
for the chip and the wireless specs that
is all so with that said let's jump into
the juicy details about that larger iMac
and what to expect from that almost
exactly one year ago German gave us some
new details about Apple still working on
a pro iMac saying that we should expect
it to come after the M3 iMac in 2023 and
we should expect it to have the M3 Pro
and M3 Max chips but the big new detail
is the confirmation that the display
size will actually be larger than 30
inches finally shutting down the leaks
of it being a 27 inch iMac Pro refresh
now if you don't remember Ross young has
been talking about the 27-inch iMac Pro
for a while which he then said could
have been the display because of the
whole Apple Studio and then a new
display that's going to have xdr specs
being 27 inches so probably because of
that we thought it would be a 27 inch
iMac Pro refresh but also the other part
of that probably stemmed from sources
who tested prototype Apple silicon iMac
models which had 27 inch displays with
the most recent prototype last year
being a 27 inch model with the new
redesign that we have with the 24 inch
iMac but in a black chassis like the old
iMac Pro and and including an M1 Max
chip which proves that apple is working
on an iMac Pro style replacement as far
as the 30 inch display I think that
makes the absolute most sense why well
because if you look at the 27 inch iMac
Pro there was a ton of bezels around the
display a ton so they can literally keep
the general size of the chassis the same
but with new thin bezels being able to
give us a 30 inch display maybe even
with rounded Corners making it look very
very good just by slimming the bezels
alone now as far as the other aspects of
the design I believe apple is going to
keep the chin on the bottom of the 30
inch iMac Pro yes keep it and that's
because I believe they're going to once
again put the entire logic board with
the chip and everything the cooling we
within just the chin of the iMac Pro now
as far as the chips I believe that the
M3 Max Chip is going to be the highest
chip you can get in the iMac Pro I don't
think the ultra is gonna work out I
think it's just way too much to cool
down within a thin iMac chassis and I
think they want to keep the ultra
reserved for the highest and Max like
the Max studio for four thousand dollars
or the Mac Pro they want to keep that
exclusive so I think the iMac Pro is
just gonna have the M3 Pro and the M3
Max that way they have a really nice
lineup going from the regular M3 chip
iMac then the iMac Pro with M3 Pro and
Max and then the ultra with the desktop
high-end machines and then of course
let's talk about the features I honestly
think that they're going to be basically
the same everything is going to be
locked down Unified memory no more
changing your RAM inside your iMac Pro
that's not going to happen anymore maybe
we're going to get some new features
like face ID integrated into the display
right above kind of being hidden that
would be really awesome but other
features I'm not really sure what they
could add maybe they could figure out a
way to add like a wireless charging Mac
safe pad built into the iMac Pro but
that's probably not likely and now let's
finally finish off with the pricing by
using two different methods the first
one is to look at the old relationship
between the Intel 27 inch iMac price and
the MacBook Pros well first of all the
5K iMac back in 2018 was three thousand
dollars with these upgrades compared to
thirty five hundred dollars for the 15
inch I9 MacBook Pro so the MacBook Pro
has always been more expensive than the
IMAX even though the iMac is actually
faster with faster dedicated graphics
the MacBook Pros were always marketed as
more expensive so the conclusion here is
that the 5K iMac was priced cheaper even
though it had a larger display and it
was faster so we can expect the same
thing to go forward with the new 30 inch
iMac Pro and then method two is to look
at the relationship between the current
24 inch iMac and the MacBook airs which
share basically the same chip now the M1
iMac was priced the exact same as the M1
MacBook Air when it first came out which
now that has been discounted to 999
dollars so the iMac currently costs the
same as the brand new 15-inch MacBook
Air which is honestly less expensive
than everybody thought it would be so I
expect the price of the new M3 24 inch
iMac to stay the same as it currently is
thirteen hundred dollars or it might get
a little bit less expensive but for the
30 inch iMac Pro Model we can conclude
that the 30 inch iMac with the M3 Pro
chip will probably cost around 1800 to 2
000 close to or as high as the 14 inch
MacBook Pro and then the M3 Max shift
version is likely going to cost around
2300 to 2500 since the max chip upgrade
right now itself is a 500 upgrade
compared to the M3 Pro because you also
have to upgrade to 32 gigs of RAM on the
M3 Max so with that said let's answer
the original question should you wait
for the M3 Pro and Max 30 inch iMac well
honestly I think that's only going to be
coming around six months after the
MacBook Pros with the M3 Pro and Max
chips and those are only going to come
about six months after the regular M3
chip if not nine months later so if
we're expecting the M3 chip to come
later this fall then we shouldn't expect
the 30-inch iMac until the end of 2024
at least or probably more likely the
spring of 2025 which is a very long time
to wait so honestly if I was a buyer
right now I wouldn't wait I would
probably just get the M2 Max Max studio
for two thousand dollars which is a
killer deal and the studio display
because all of it just works so well and
if you really want an all-in-one system
I think the new M3 iMac that's going to
be coming maybe later this year or the
spring is going to be a great option as
well so let me know your thoughts on
these new leaks down in the comment
section below and click the circle above
to subscribe for more videos like this
one thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
all right